[Applause]
good morning dear colleagues we have
with us
today the president of Portugal Marcelo
rebello de Souza
president
welcome president thank you for being
here today this house in 2016.
you anticipated many of our common
challenges and spoke of issues that
continue to be relevant today
in the face of adversity you called for
Unity and solidarity because you
understood
already then that we had more to gain by
working together
that is how we dealt with the pandemic
that is how we stood up to the Russian
aggression in Ukraine president I would
like to commend you on your efforts in
protecting our European values and in
fighting social exclusion
the social and economic impact of the
war in Ukraine the energy prices and an
increased inflation rate across our
Union are once again testing our unity
and commitment towards those values
the call for more unity and solidarity
is perhaps today more pressing than ever
before this is the moment to stand
together this is Europe's moment to stay
United new political and security
challenges pose a greater more complex
threat to our democracies the rise of
populism and neuroskepticism fueled by
information Warfare and disinformation
campaigns seek to erode trust in
Democratic institutions by hampering
citizens from making informed decisions
how we responded to this and how we will
continue to respond to those looking to
undermine our democracy will be the
litmus test of our values here I am
convinced that Portugal will continue to
play its part surveys after surveys show
that the Portuguese population is
exceedingly euro-optimistic especially
about the future of the European Union
this is encouraging and yet we must keep
doing more more to bring the message of
Europe closer to our people more to show
that the values that bind us as
Europeans is still so much greater than
what can ever seek to divide us and more
to assure our citizens that their vote
at the European elections next year does
in fact matter estimado president
foreign
[Applause]
president
honorable members
I should like to begin with three short
preliminary remarks
just a few words because time is short
and Europe has no time to lose
you madam president and you're young
determined and Visionary mandate
confirming that in the current Europe
there is room for everyone without
inevitable differences at geography
history demography the or the cultural
social economic or political diversity
foreign
secondly
I wish to recall on behalf of Portugal
our gratitude openness and solidarity
towards this Union of peoples which
gives us Liberty Justice democracy
and empowerment
and all of us together
we can live together
in solidarity
Portugal was still is and will always be
on the front line on the Forefront of
defensive defending Europe and the
European Union
thirdly
to recall that
it's seven years ago that I was here on
the 13th of April 2016.
one month and four days after my taking
up office
at a different time in a different world
in a different Europe
people still believed in the
international order the albeit in crisis
we still believed in the balance of
powers albeit shifting
we believed in institutional reforms in
Universal institutions albeit delayed we
believed in European security
as inherited in the mid-20th century
albeit fragile
we believed in the Triumph of
diplomacy over War albeit complicated in
the advancement of Human Rights albeit
if difficult
we believed in the privacy of
globalization multilateralism
and
shared causes human rights the climate
our oceans migration refugees terrorism
poverty inequality
women's empowerment the fight against
child poverty the renewal of political
economic and social systems
foreign
was still a union of 28.
before the referendum of the United
Kingdom
with national and European leaders
other leaders and many believed that
reforms could be postponed
as well as bringing together Europeans
and widening the Union
just for a while nobody knew quite how
long
excellencies
the time for delay in wavering is over
and it came to an abrupt end with two
years of pandemic and a further year of
War
an illegal War
an unjust War an immoral War
a shocking error of the Russian
Federation
one that the European Union responded to
in a principled way with a firm response
with solidarity and transatlantic
cooperation in a future-oriented way
I see in this way
a parliamentary term went by
it was almost a full political cycle
that passed
a cycle spent living under emergency
under a pandemic and its waves economics
stand still and the social impacts
War
a crisis
of energy and inflation and many
cumulative social impacts
and in this time of emergency one must
cope one day at a time one is less
available and able to reflect on the big
questions that face our Union that face
all Europeans each of us
and we're now just one year from the
European elections
excellencies
what are the vital questions that we
must
face up to during these decisive years
ahead
one plus seven
easy to list but much harder to answer
first of all
the most urgent one
ensure that
when the people of Ukraine emerge from
this war
and the peoples of the world and in
Europe emerge
a legal
just and moral peace can emerge
in respect of international law and
human rights
preventing future Wars
and giving rise to a new future for all
those living in times of uncertainty
both economic and social
and
further seven questions
that will
face Us in the medium and long term
first question
post-war post-economic recovery does the
union wish to emerge as a genuine
effective Global power yes or no
in the new balance of powers not an
international order just yet which will
take longer to emerge
established powers
weakened powers
as a result of raw and Econo economic
change what role will the European Union
play my answer is a simple one
the strongest possible role the biggest
possible role
Unity will be the only answer otherwise
we will be thus playing the weakest
possible part
second question
which European Union are we speaking of
with enlargement and if so then how
my response is yes with enlargement
and also
the best possible
way and with the best possible
institutional political preparation and
economic support possible and it is only
with sound preparation that uh
enlargement will be a positive change
for all concerned lack of preparation
could lead to uh disappointment on a
huge scale for all those who have
legitimate wishes for this to come about
third question
a European Union but what what economic
power
that is to say what
ability to recover
for economic and social recovery
with adversity on all sides internally
and externally
my response and it's the only possible
response
is to say
we need to think of the sacrifices that
millions of Europeans are making
and we must
speed up economic recovery
we cannot play down the
indirect social effects and also the
political impact of inflation
the combined effects of pandemic and War
economic recovery
of the European Union must gain pace
and in this way we need to bring
Europeans
closer to Europe
fourth question the European Union
led by what governing guidelines
economic guidelines in the medium and
long term especially when we give
thought to enlargement to include more
member states
who have legitimate expectations when it
comes to European funds
my response and the only possible
response is to not postpone
the clarification of these financial and
economic guidelines for our future
any delay any postponement
will make everything harder
much more difficult to solve these
problems later down the line
fifth question
a European Union but with what uh policy
for relations with other continents
this goes beyond migration policy
we are talking about a genuine policy
for relations with other continents does
the European Union wish to stay distant
closed in on itself
due to past and recent causes like the
pandemic like the war
or
does the union wish to be alert
proactive
the European Union
must not forget
that
on other continents
it is very difficult
for people to understand that this is
not a European war and but a global war
and for the European Union it must not
forget
the agreements and Partnerships
it has
with
key continents like Africa Latin America
and in certain cases with Asia as well
the European Union cannot postpone
the questions that will if left
abandoned will cause migration and
complex situations for the world over
the
egotism must be subordinated to European
values
sixth question does the European Union
wish to remain a Pioneer on the climate
and energy transition yes or no but also
for digital knowledge and Science and or
would the European Union prefer
to wait until the end of this era
to begin to tackle these challenges
my answer
these questions cannot be divorced from
one another the European Union wishing
to be a global power must also
be a Pioneer on climate must also be a
climate in the field of science
technology knowledge digital
Technologies and energy
and if that is not the case we will be
left behind and Europe will not become a
global power
seventh question
a European Union at the service of Youth
solidarity between the generations
generational shifts within political
economic and social systems
or
a union that is slow to renew itself
slow to
um
to rebuild its societies and lagging
behind other continents we must be able
to react and anticipate I have no doubt
whatsoever
my response
and the only possible response must be
that the European Union should
accelerate generational changes
we cannot forget young people
sacrifice them
in Social and economic terms
in times of war and pandemic we must
support and focus on youth
we cannot sideline young people we
cannot alienate young people
we must increase youth participation
rejuvenate political systems economic
and social systems of Our member states
failure to do this will open up vacuums
vacuums that will be filled by
anti-system movements and populism
and if this happens we will be to blame
not the populists not these other
movements
which simply do what they seek to do
simply because we failed to do what we
must
and failed to do it in time
before it was too late
and short
there is a pressing need
we must face this war open up a path
towards peace a legal just and moral
peace
and then
we have these seven questions for the
new political cycle which will run from
2024 to 20 to 29.
bearing in mind that even before 2029
numerous national leaders will reach the
end of their political terms and in some
cases without the possibility for
re-election
in short we face
two ways forward we are at a fork
on one side
due to war and slowed recovery we manage
things on a day-to-day basis we resolve
pressing needs and hold back
waiting for the next uh electoral period
post 2024
but there is another way
to not
stay content ourselves with vague ideas
or get
dragged down in
meaningless institutional discussions
that mean nothing to European citizens
the other path
is one that is based on the
understanding that we can only win our
future with a medium to long-term vision
if we're able to anticipate
that future and
ward off the frustrations
and problems it is true that Europe was
built over time with progress on
setbacks quite often achieving what
seemed impossible at the 11th Hour
we live in times of uh un predictability
in times of crisis
but uncertainty has often become a
certainty in the past let us not use
this as an pretext to shirk away from
doing the things we must do
let us take this as an excitement an
encouragement to take the actions that
we need to do to take leadership and to
look to the medium and long-term future
I
Portugal the people of Portugal believe
in Europe
I Portugal the people of Portugal
believe in the values and principles
that found it we believe in Freedom
pluralism democracy solidarity
social justice
and
therefore also in human rights
we the Portuguese people want a Europe
that is stronger a Europe that
plays a leadership role that is
anticipating the future and doesn't
stay on the back foot
I and the Portuguese people believe in
the future
a Europe that doesn't belong to heads of
state heads of government
or party leaders
doesn't belong to political and social
leaders a Europe that belongs to the men
and women of Europe
because this is the Europe that we want
for our future
if these
men and women do not inherit a strong
Europe
um in the world
that is the challenge that we face
we have precious little time to prepare
this future and Europe deserves it
the millions of Europeans deserve it
and the world deserves a stronger Europe
and Europe as always will prevail
[Applause]
thank you very very much president thank
you the session will now close and we
will resume with the votes thank you
very much president for that amazing
speech
[Applause]